curse Clara and bleh black food clothes
and housing those are the concerns the
country conquerors from great in South
Africa are singing about Marshall r
inquest as one of the Bands founders he
knows the needs of many people here and
that's why he's active in the community
in the evening Marshall plays with his
band in the daytime he goes to schools
to demonstrate that protecting the
climate and the environment can make
life easier for everyone morning morning
guys are you a good the students garden
almost every day growing their own food
to avoid transporting produce over long
distances that's an important part of
the transition town idea in addition
it's cheaper for families than buying
vegetables our main goal as each one
season town is to to reduce our carbon
footprint as far as possible that's like
I would say we still busy making a kind
of a foundation on trans seasons as
getting people inspired to learn more
green recycle to reduce the carbon
footprint Rodney cupido is the school
principal here he sees climate
protection as beneficial because
electricity is expensive in South Africa
that's why he wants to install solar
collectors in the school reducing the
carbon footprint plays just one role
among many electricity bills are 45
thousand per month of school don't
charge any school fees
and we need to get some means to earn
money and by installing solar panels on
our big roof we will be able to earn
money by selling the electricity and
with that money we can buy books we can
pay for the transports taking the layer
now and also getting the learner to
school and that will improve education
and quality teaching at the school until
now there have been few solar collectors
here primarily among farmers in the
surrounding area the principal meets
Eugene barley he's an engineer who sees
his task as free and great in from its
dependence on fossil fuels by using
renewable solar energy it will save the
poor people money we also have a small
businesses that will benefit from the
solar energy within in turn can create
more work employment we also have the
solar the climate change issues that we
have to contend with we have
environmental issues and that is why
solar energy will be beneficial when you
see here is on a small scale and we want
to roll this out over the big grayton
area so that everybody can benefit from
it some 8,000 people live in grayton and
the neighboring communities that
belonged to the transition town
initiative one aspect of the project is
to bridge differences between the
prosperous central town and poor
outlying areas Marshall rehnquist lives
in Bossman's kloof not far from grayton
many here like money and prospects it
wasn't easy for people to actually get
to UM get with each other but I think
now that they actually working together
with John season there's some more bond
with other way there you can actually
share ideas in terms of our knowledge of
our people and so to call white people
ill time is running out graton is also
being affected by climate change at the
river on the edge of town r in class
shows how the effects can already be
seen
in the last 10-15 years temperature went
about higher from the five degrees to 45
and also we got more rain in the last 10
20 years as a result you can see the
river that flowed years for a small one
but it caught out by the big of the
little bank on that side and also the
side as well we with it was just fine
boss and at the moment it's just the
open piece of land to get more people
behind the transition town project the
trash to treasure festival takes place
every year in grayton on a rubbish dump
children make eco bricks from plastic
waste by stuffing empty bottles with
plastic scraps soon that's set to create
jobs and protect the climate because the
bricks can be used to build affordable
housing for poor people helping solve
the housing shortage in the area walls
made with the bottles are well insulated
that saves energy using simple means I
can make a frame and I can put chicken
wire I can ball them you oh and i can
take clay and i put it here in the front
side and I can take cop and I follow the
strong one or both and i get no went
inside and I know this one can can use
it for a long year
josephs dajjal started the trash to
treasure festival he came to great in
from the US just under two years ago
attracted by novel ideas put to use in
the town what we're really doing here
with the trash to treasure festival it's
very much an initiative of the global
transition town network and we're we're
showing people how they can use the
great majority of everything they throw
away on a daily basis to aid community
resilience to grow food to insulate
their homes and a big part of this is
the Eco brick this simple technology of
using a plastic bottle stuffing your
plastic trash into it and and really
sequestering that carbon that would
otherwise be released into the
environment Marshall rehnquist and his
country conquerors have composed a song
about eco bricks especially for the
festival it's meant as encouragement
because the challenges facing the
community are huge the transition town
movement has awakened hopes of a better
life among many poor people initiators
now have to fulfill them